اعتقد انه
الرياض الرياض تريد تهدئه المنطقه عموما
تريد الاستقرار في المنطقه
ربما عوده سوريا لها علاقه
بالاتفاقيه هذه الاخيره مع مع ايران بين
الرياض وطهران
فربما ربما يعني هذا تخمين مني انه ربما
ادخال سوريا في
في
يعني عوده عوده سوريه الى المنطقه والى
الى العالم العربي هو
من ناحيه انه ربما ايران تضغط على
الحوثيون على الحوثيين في اليمن
وتساعد في
تقليص من وطاه وهي ماده الحوثيين خاصه
الضربات هذه اللي اللي كانوا يطلقونها على
المملكه ما اعتقد انه رياض او المملكه
ستساعد سوريا اقتصاديا او ستعطي اموال
لاعاده بناء سوريا هذه كلها
يعني اجراءات
الها علاقه
بالاستقرار
وتهدئه المنطقه
ما هي يعني انه ما تغير رؤيه النظام رؤيه
النظام السوري في الرياض لم يتغير هل هي
نظام رياضيات اليوم بالمعروف في
تريد بالفعل
اخراج ايران ميليشياتها في المنطقه من
سوريا تحديدا هل من ضمن شروط مثلا
لا ما اعتقد ما اعتقد انه الايران ايران
ستخرج جماعتها من سوريا ابدا هي هيمنه على
البلد هذا وهيمنه على لبنان وهيمنه على
العراق يعني
المهم بالنسبه للسعوديه للمملكه هي اليمن
والاردن
يعني لبنان هي مشكله لاسرائيل الغرب اكثر
ما انها مشكله للسعوديه نفس الشيء سوريا
بس هذه الفكره ما تنسف اي محاولات
او
لاعاده العلاقات مع ايران ما زالت متمسكه
بوجود ميليشياته لتخدم مصالحها في هذه
الدول دكتور واللي تتعارض اكيد مع مصالح
السعوديه ودول اخرى
اكيد يعني
النظام الايراني نظام ثوري يريد اخراج
امريكا من المنطقه يريد ان يهيمن على
المنطقه
من ناحيه من وجهه نظر السعوديه هي انه كيف
تقلص او كيف تحد من حركه ايران
التي تريد ان تزعزع الوضع وتهيمن على
المنطقه